ce lundi vers 9h30 une jeune fille de 18
ans est poignardé dans un train reliant
rambouillet à paris montparnasse au
niveau de coignières elle voulait se
courir une femme giflé par son compagnon
l'homme n'apprécie pas et lui porte un
coup de couteau à l'abdomen
le signal d'alarmé alors tiré par
d'autres passagers l'individu est arrêté
en gare de coignières par les forces de
l'ordre
la victime est conduite à l'hôpital
georges pompidou à paris
elle est désormais hors de danger selon
les premiers éléments de l'enquète elle
connaissait la jeune fille malmené étant
dans le même établissement scolaire
le suspect âgé de 17 ans a été placé en
garde à vue au commissariat d'elancourt
jusqu'à ce mardi soir il n'est pas connu
des services de police